a man walks carefully down a street
totally destroyed
russian bombs have ripped through these
buildings in central kharkiv
the area is silent and brutally scarred
shrapnel has ripped through cars
masonry
thrown in the blasts has crushed others
flames still rise from buildings nearby
bomb craters
and twisted steel
this street in central kharkiv shows you
just how devastating
the effect of russian bombing of this
city has
been an entire street
totally destroyed
many of these buildings
have people's homes in them
private residences flats some of them
still smoking
one of the main things that many people
here tell you
is that they can in no way understand
how the leader of a country like
russia
could do something like this
to a city like kharkiv
tasa is in shock
she walks around in the days looking at
the destroyed businesses and homes
he went here
[Music]
i cannot think straight i can't find the
words
it's barbaric terrible the world is
shaking
[Music]
i just don't understand
shrapnel has ripped through the golden
spires of an orthodox church
every window is smashed
underground metro stations is where many
people hide
young and old stand patiently in line
for food served by volunteers
a bowl of soup salad and bread
elona and her 12 year old daughter
nastia show us the train carriage where
they've sheltered since their home was
destroyed
it started 12 days ago our house was
destroyed
we don't know where to live anymore
i don't know where to go with my child
honestly help us
there are many here like us who have
lost everything
their belongings are neatly arranged
where they sleep
there are family pets here too
i thought we would live peacefully in
happiness united but i was wrong
[Music]
in another carriage we find 19 year old
violetta and her baby son bogdan
he was born in hospital two days after
the russian army invaded
it's so difficult
every day we wash him upstairs
i'm so worried about him getting cold
vladimir putin told the world repeatedly
russia would never invade ukraine
kharkiv
is a terrified testimony to his lie
john stratford al jazeera kharkiv